here we are in glasgow central been
speaking to the leading candidates in
the contest for the seat while joining
me now for the spr allison Thewlis and
for labor and I saw a welcome to you
both I suppose a big question is could
your two parties ever work together in
government reality is we are campaigning
for a majority labour government we
don't want the SNP do when the SMP don't
want us to win Barry understand that and
whoever is the largest part it will form
the government that's why it's crucial
to every seat you were in Scotland Texas
all that finishing length and then what
we'll do afterwards if we are the
largest party we will seek to form a
government we will write a liberal
budget and then we do the sm so you know
we will write a labour budget and we
dear them to vote against them well I'll
accept says he's gonna watch it neither
fairly that he was joking on that on
that point I'm but I don't see why
they're there are issues in which we
have used a Labour Party I'm a mansion
tax and bankers bonuses and taxes I
don't see why we can't work together on
those things and while also seeking to
make that government a theater of
government and by doing things like
composing and yeah trident because
you're manifester did look but with the
exception of Trident really stealing a
lot of Labor's clothes well like I say
there are things that we agree on and
there's absolutely no reason why parties
can't work together really have common
cause there's a difference there Adam is
the SNP want full fiscal autonomy which
means that all the money that's raised
in Scotland stairs and Scott will
display in the Scottish public services
alison mentions the mansion tax night in
tax only one third of a percent of the
mansion tax will be raised in Scotland
but we would still get ten percent on
that money spent in Scotland meaning a
thousand more nauseous but our NHS and
600 more GPS that shows you the
difference and always wanted to
redistribute wealth across united
kingdom we just should be away from the
south of England away from London and
North it to score again the perfect
example with the bankers bonus thanks
the bank is born as facts attacks reason
learn again one minute will you do with
your chameleon seats a little bit well I
believe in redistribution and that
mansion tax means I say that bankers
bonus cash museum a very visual your
colleagues in London will take their
seats as well absolutely and that means
six thousand young people in this city
Glasgow will get a guaranteed job
because of our bankers bonus
primarily on London they seem for the
north wing I mean you accept that if
there was for fiscal autonomy you would
be short of money here we accept that in
film festival autonomy is not going to
happen overnight that would be a gradual
process to get to that and by actually
having the powers within Scotland same
overall economy we would actually be
able to try and make more money into
that economy to make better choices for
the people of Scotland rather than
having that driven by because I mean
Institute for Fiscal Studies they did
say that according to your plans they've
looked at them austerity gone longer
cuts were going longer than they would
under labour for example well the first
the former First Minister Salman
severely Lorna believe that the figures
are in connect and from our point of
view and leave it of also challenged the
number of figures within the IFS report
the way is clear is that we are the only
party that isn't committed to cuts labor
Tory's lib dems or what the sea cuts we
want to see more despondent spending
increases which would be a benefit was
in Scotland and for the rest of the
United yes if you can see the experts
are wrong some of the time but they
can't see the experts are wrong all of
the tape the ifs that the eye effect is
now independent and you just saying that
wrong as well as day independence racial
studies I said that would be deeper cuts
with the full fiscal autonomy plans and
a store austerity would last longer than
our sins already accepted that she wants
full autonomy if it was put to a
position was it slowly and I wouldn't
necessarily have what he would work
impact on table that means in practice
she says she supports the mansion tax we
wouldn't get we would only get one
federal percent of a mansion tax in
Scotland rather than ten percent she
says she supports the bankers bonus tax
we wouldn't be able to use that bankers
bonus fact to guarantee a job for six
thousand young people in byesville she
says she supports of have to be taxed
and we wouldn't get that money come into
Scotland as I said we're not going to
get full fiscal autonomy over light the
systems are in place to snow I load up
the way that money's come to Scotland in
the short term the first that we were
promised unto them under the long time
we will get to that will get more
control over at a corner and never
thought I mean tax money and we'll get
the bankers bonds tax money will get the
[ __ ] to be taxman money that's bad for
Scotland know people to bring in other
money and doing other things I me here
no choice is rather late Bob each other
you brought me said there we would
actually and looks a big I'm more money
into things like game removing Trident
which is 250 million pounds the bank
bonus tax brings in much more than that
the mansion tax brings in almost a
billion pounds we look to make changes
in the economy as well and will child
care so that more women could get to
work we look to and do things like and
actually reduce the impact of the
welfare reforms and benefit cuts and so
that people would actually be able to
spend on any economy as well and where
does independence come as a priority for
you this isn't then about independence
the selection you had that effort end in
Y September we accept same nor one
that's not for a generation we are quite
clear that we're not looking to have
another referendum in the short term
certainly it's not in this manifest or
it would depend it off a lot in the
circumstances that happen in the next
few years so for example if there where
a referendum fatique and so is it you
and that might change things of the rest
of the UK BOTS and Scotland anything you
that Scotland and wheels Northern
Ireland want 2cn that might change
things as well and we're certainly not
looking to do that this election is not
only one of the independence referendum
so since none of the scare stories about
the SNP that really applied we've had
the referendum is all over doesn't well
first hasn't asked useful full fiscal
autonomy that is damaging to our public
services installed secondly Nicola
Sturgeon Waterloo a referendum in the
2016 manifesto and the best way of
avoiding an EU referendum is a Labour
government we've had constitution of
politics debated in Scotland for the
last two years let's talk about poverty
let's talk about anything you need for
food banks let's talk about getting
education for our young people unless
they were the Liberal government we're
gonna have to run either thank you both
very much indeed for Jonas well in all
we've had for our of the candidates
standing in this constituted glasgow
central on Sky News Tonight they are the
Conservatives Simon bone for the tsc
Canada Andrew Elliot for the Greens
casts McGregor for cannabis is safe than
alcohol James Maris for you Kip Stewart
Maskull for Socialist Equality Katie
roads for labor and the sower the SNP
Alison Thewlis and also the Liberal
Democrat Chris Young